am I off on this I thought one of
Strickland's worst performances it was
still a close fight I don't know what's
going through Strickland's head and I'd
like to talk to Nick sick about it he
always breaks guys will and it's he
doesn't wait till the fifth to do it
it's usually this point in the second or
third round where you see just a switch
flip and then it's just this Onslaught
until the guy breaks and it just never
came I was like waiting waitting I went
something Strickland's off R's like yeah
he's in a tough fight like he's been
tough fights before and then there's
something that's what makes Sea
different that's what makes him a
different breed you can see his
mentality switches and he just kind of
just slowly chipping away chipping away
chipping away and then sudden it starts
going faster because starts fight he's
going like this this is the Rhythm boof
boof boof seconds boof boof boof third
boof boof boof
fourth it breaks that's what makes him
special is he is just he's like a tidal
waveman until you break it just never
came it could that could be credit DDP